hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my arrow episode 21 video
lots of comic-book stuff that we have to
work through including the person that
might end up being the season 4 villain
it's just as the big rumor that was
going around a couple months ago was
that the finale would tee up whoo the
season 4 villains gonna be and they
basically called him out in this episode
so careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen 21 yet starting with top five
moments number five meet damian darhk--
probably gonna be the arrow season 4
villain so as rachel is like slowly
brainwashing and training oliver using
the the fear toxin from Batman Begins no
less he explains the damian darhk-- was
a person who joined the league the same
time he did but ended up hopping on the
crazy train and created a splinter
organization to carry on the league's
work as he saw it
rage tasks Oliver with taking damien
down this is just the beginning damian
darhk-- has actually character from the
teen titans comics I know everyone
always asked about the Titans show
that's happening on TNT they've actually
changed the name of that show it's not
called Titans anymore but I'll talk
about that in another video
damian debuted in titans number one in
1999 he really only existed inside that
arc it was like a 12 issue arc so in
issue number 12 he ended up being killed
by Vandal Savage he hasn't appeared in
the new 52 comics but he's a big hive
character and he gets tied up with Slade
Wilson's wife her name is Alan Kane so
if they're gonna be doing damian darhk--
hive in season 4 it'd be an easy way to
bring Deathstroke back on the show and
they said they can't do that even though
the Suicide Squad movie might be doing
Deathstroke they could still do him on
the show they can still bring Manu
Bennett so they tied Amy and dark to all
these past events on the show like
trying to buy the prototype of Merlin's
earthquake machine killing diggle's
brother they'll continue to do that and
what I'm hoping that they do is that
they tie him to felicity he ends up
being Felicity's father in the comics
Damian's known for his baby face I don't
know how the show's gonna address this
because supposedly only a ratio ghoul
has access to Lazarus pits so we might
see the same kind of thing going on with
Damian he might just be like a really
old person in a young person's body
moving on so number four
Oliver League of Assassins training
montage I really like the way they shot
the opening scene do it just like
cutting over the course of a couple
weeks Oliver slowly gets brainwashed
with the fear toxin and gets really
badass
swords they're not only brainwashing him
they're also training him to fight even
though team arrows seem like they'd
almost given up on him by the end of the
episode
there is no programming that cannot be
broken somehow something is going to
happen to redeem him at a certain point
whether or not they carried into season
4 we have no idea I always like how they
try to trip you up with like an opening
moment WTF like him stabbing Diggle but
then you know then it turns out it's
someone else great way to start an
episode make everyone poop their pants
on to number three Laurel and Nyssa are
milkshake gal pals I really like the way
they developed a friendship between
those two characters Nyssa is such an
awesome character so I'm just happy to
have her on the show I think it's a good
way to humanize her and give Laurel a
really nice arc that has absolutely
nothing to do with the rest of team
arrow like they can just have their own
scenes off on their own
mostly Nyssa trying to train her the
same way she trained Sara that's gonna
take a long time but now that she has
the canary cry I think she'll learn to
use that too and it'll help close some
of that distance is this really
interesting dichotomy they had between
Oliver and Nyssa whereby she slowly
gains her humanity in Oliver's like
losing his at the same time it's too bad
they captured her at the end of the
episode because I was kind of hoping
that she joined team arrow like the new
team arrow for a little while I
definitely have to give Laurel props
though for being the voice of reason
it's like everybody is losing their
except for Laurel she's kind of like the
moral conscience of team arrow right now
moving on to number two though Oliver
kidnaps Laurel and threatens her life I
don't think we were ever in any danger
of Oliver killing Lyla but it's still
really heartbreaking to see him go up
against his arrow bro Diggle Lyla had
that really nice speech about how
joining team arrow helped humanize
Diggle like after the war he was
suffering from post-traumatic stress but
Oliver helped give him a purpose it
seems like it's all falling on deaf ears
right now but you know I think at a
certain point something will happen to
shock Oliver back to consciousness and
if you're wondering all those team arrow
scenes where they were meeting that was
inside ray Palmer's lab that's gonna be
like the temporary arrow cave you call
it the atom cave if you want eventually
ray will step in and help out but he
wasn't really necessary for this episode
it was mostly about classic og team
arrow versus Oliver and of course my
number one WTF moment ratio goal tells
Nyssa that she is now the bride of the
demon and asks Oliver to unleash the
Omega
Starlin you can kind of see how we're
drifting into Christopher Nolan Batman
territory here destroy the city wipe it
clean and I can't just casually drop
that the previous ratio goal his
predecessor wiped out Alexandria like a
biblical plague that was kind of a Bible
moment where he asked Oliver to kill
Nyssa it was like when God asked Abraham
to kill his son Isaac and then when he
went in to do it God stopped Abraham and
said no this was just a test and you
passed right of the demon though I like
to think about was like the the Bride of
Frankenstein scream when Elsa Lanchester
just screams out loud with a crazy hair
Marc Guggenheim did tease that there
would be another wedding on arrow this
season that wasn't diggle's I think
we'll see some kind of ceremony don't
expect it to actually go down I don't
think they'll make it to the vows
hopefully it'll actually go down in next
week's episode that's this what I'm
looking forward to it's like next week
we deal with the wedding stuff then the
week after that we deal with the Omega
Starling stuff that really only just
scratches the surface of the episode but
here's my big question for you guys how
do you think the team arrow is going to
help Oliver shake his programming
whatever they end up doing it's gonna be
something that they have to do together
like it'll be all of them together in
the same moment if you remember in the
mid-season finale when Oliver died he
all those images flashed through his
brain I wonder if the same type of thing
is gonna happen like what if he ended up
dying and they dumped him in the lazarus
pit and he comes out changed that'd be
pretty crazy remember this last scene in
this episode they were standing in front
of the lazarus pit so I just I feel like
the Lazarus Pit is gonna continue to be
a big plot point before season 4
somebody else needs to get dumped in
there speaking of the Lazarus Pit let's
talk about Thea for a second so Felicity
tells her that Roy's still alive so
obviously she's gonna track him down we
saw him in the promo for the next
episode don't really know if Roy's gonna
be in the finale but he's probably gonna
help her on her road to becoming a
superhero she's slowly moving towards
the Mia Dearden speedy she's not gonna
change her name or anything and I don't
know exactly what her final costume will
look like but she was wearing a hood in
this episode so she's like halfway there
she'll probably just get a mask like
they all wear which also actually brings
up the idea of a Diggle costume don't
say the word costume Felicity just
teased that he should start using some
more ident
concealment if he's gonna be hitting the
streets more often I know everybody
wants to see dick go get a costume but
he's not gonna get a costume it'll just
be like slightly more secure gear I will
say my only minor complaint about the
episode was the the plot point about the
Alpha the Omega with the flashbacks it's
been like such a huge thing all season
long with the flashbacks but they just
now tied it back to present-day I think
the flashbacks work a little bit better
when you know scene to scene flashback
to present day within each episode sync
up more the flashbacks this season it
felt a little uneven as you can see the
hitting the fan on both flash and
arrow Grodd is coming to the flash next
week so be sure to subscribe to get that
video a lot of people requested a speedy
bonus video so I'll try to get that out
as soon as possible mate you know maybe
next week or at least the week after why
you guys wait for all that stuff in case
you haven't seen it I just posted an
agents of shield Avengers crossover
video you can click here to watch it and
you can click here for this week's
episode of the flash thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tomorrow
you